two common errors in this part one here
the first was that people landed on this
line there's some QP vector people who
use that but they didn't say why they
didn't say anything about why is that
all right why is it I there why is it a
negative I why is there a K why am I for
some reason multiplying through so you
can see my wording here we are very
resistant to writing words because it
takes a long time and it's totally ok to
not write words don't mind getting no
marks because you haven't reasoned
through okay so you really have to give
some explanation that's more than just
the lines more than just the actual
algebra once you said that the other
problem was that people had a were
confused about the directions of the
vectors they didn't just distinguish
between a vector that went like this
versus a vector that went like that okay
the direction you are heading in where
you start where you end is critically
important QP PQ different vectors say
magnitude but the important thing about
what makes the vectors are not scalars
is that they're facing in a particular
direction okay so that was our what was
problematic with part one part two there
are a couple of different ways to do it
but please note it says Express MQ that
vector in terms of W and then that
little word there hence she had to use
that you could have used other reasoning
like saying oh keep o QP are going to be
Kansai click every every triangle is
contact but Oh P is going to be a
diameter why is it a diameter hope is a
daba da because o QP is a right angle
and the Anglin a semi circle is PI on to
okay I'm you could have taken advantage
of that but you still needed to refer to
this vector in somewhere okay now I'm
just gonna pause for a second there it's
recess now I'd really love to finish
this we're pretty close what do you
think yeah okay good I'm sorry can we
get the window is that a wreck we shut
that because I'm sure you're going to be
people with your past yeah push hard
don't don't go easy on it put your back
into it
okay well done you're you're worthy so
that's great
uh-huh this question here was very
poorly answered now it's um it's not
that hard it's not that hard when you
think about the concepts here you are
absorbing simultaneously okay I know how
to do that I need to show that they even
say the right angles so that's something
to do with gradient right
so you can see how I have gone through
this I said let's just call the place
where they intersect let's give it a
name okay once I've got that point I
want to solve where they're equal
together and I want to know about their
gradients at those points okay so that's
why you can see I've differentiated I am
going to combine them now I knew
immediately I had to combine them why
why did the question told me that if
they intersect at right angles then that
product should be negative 1 now that's
great because that gives me a really
clear path for where I need to be
simplifying I'm not just randomly
throwing in trig identities right so you
can see here I've just multiplied 1
derivative by the other that gives me
this I've just said okay well that SEC
squared it belongs on the denominator
and here's where we had some trouble
right students didn't know where to go
from here they didn't know where to go
because over here on the right hand side
can you see there was some simplifying
you could do there because if the the
graphs intersect cause X is equal to tan
X for this particular value which I have
called alpha you call it a quarter fire
or theater or whatever but for whatever
value you can substitute through cos
alpha for tan alpha okay you see you see
what I've done there you can see how
I've used one of the cosines here to
come up to the top become tan and then I
said why I want this to be ten as well
it had better be because I supposed to
get to negative one and so that's that's
how I got to my result okay all right
once you got to there most people were
ok with part two there was a little bit
sad how many people just sort of forgot
that part two because I can't do part
one okay you didn't really need to have
proved part one you could have just gone
ahead and said all right cos x equals
tan X that's just solving simultaneously
for
quadratic from that how do you think I
knew that I had to get everything in
terms of science look at the question
it's a sign inverse right so the line
immediately before this is that sign x
equals root 5 minus 1 or 2 you can see
that from this result right and so
that's how I do well I better get there
it means I go to solve for sine X so
that gave me the idea to actually
translate into that way make the
appropriate substitution okay all right
ah
Part C two problems here two problems
the first one was that we saw that X
minus 1 on the denominator and you're
like cool substitute off my go but it
didn't help you it didn't help you
some of you realize the error of your
ways and like no no undo but some of you
just tried to play through and it didn't
get you anywhere so you've got to be
able to notice the same as integration
by parts Sam is with recurrence
relations if it's not making your
integrand simpler
you've got to abandon in a try again ok
secondly oh this was so sad we cried we
cried really hard
some people ended up with this integrand
and you were just rushed and confused
and didn't remember basic index laws
okay so after I finished wiping away my
tears I have put this together please
please PLEASE simple algebra ok don't
don't do that and then you got your
value K equals 4 ah last part of part
question 15 it looks intimidating oh
right you're like oh my goodness look at
that diagram you had to be careful with
your geometry yeah yeah questions like
this of it and it was still poorly done
it was still poorly done right some
people went ahead and calculated volume
good for you so happy for you
and I just ignored your work okay so
read the question read the question as
you guys know the hardest part of most
of these will use my similar cross
section area is getting the cross
section and then the integration is
quite simple